wanda
what do you know about the multiverse
the multiverse is the idea that beyond
our observable universe other universes
exist as well the multiversal is a
concept about which we now frighteningly
live
one of the ideas that marvel is working
with is called the many worlds
interpretation of quantum mechanics
which suggests the presence of branching
timelines that every possible outcome of
every decision that you've ever made
leads to its own distinct timeline
[Music]
but the only timeline that you're aware
of is the one that you inhabit
[Music]
you open the doorway between universes
multiverses by definition are
independent from ours and inaccessible
to us and so that makes it really tricky
to empirically test for their presence
we tap it with the stability of
space-time
it's interesting to think about a
reality that exceeds our perceptual
capabilities
and kind of mind-blowing and
mind-bending and fun
we can't control everything
things just got out of hand
[Music]